I think that fundamentalists and
atheistic scientists have the same
problem the fundamentalists so we could
say the Christian fundamentalists in the
US make the proposition that biblical
stories will call the mythological
stories our literal representations of
the truth but and that might be true
depending on what you mean by literal
but what they mean by literal or what
they attempt to make literal mean is
that they're in the same category as
scientific facts because they don't have
the idea that there are different ways
of approaching truth and and that truths
can serve different purposes they don't
have a sense that your definition of
truth is actually something like a tool
rather than an ontological statement
about the reality of the world and so
the the fundamentalists basically make
the proposition that the idea that God
created the world in six days five
thousand years ago is literally true and
they get the five thousand year estimate
by the way by going through the
genealogies in the Old Testament and
adding up the hypothetical ages and
figuring out you know how long before
Moses Adam lived and some Bishop did
that back in the I think it was in the
mid 1800s I might be wrong about that
but it was somewhere back about that
time and more or less that's being
accepted as canonical fact ever since
and then the scientists say well yeah
those are empirical truths they're just
wrong see then that's the only
difference there is between the
fundamentalist and the Atheist
scientists the fundamentalist say those
are fundamental scientific truths and
they're right and the scientists say
well they're scientific truths they just
happen to be wrong well I think that's a
stupid argument personally I mean for a
bunch of reasons one is that the people
who wrote the the ancient stories that
we have access to were in no way shape
or form scientists you know modern
people tend to think that you think like
a scientist and people have always
thought that way first of all you do not
think like a scientist even scientists
hardly even think like scientists but if
you're not scientifically trained you
don't think like a scientist at all
so one of the things for example that
characterizes your thinking is
confirmation bias and so if you have a
theory
what you do is wander around in the
world looking for reasons why it's true
and the scientist does exactly the
opposite of that in the little tiny
narrow domain where he or she is
actually capable of being a scientist
and what they have is a theory and look
for a way to prove it wrong but believe
me you don't run around doing that
I mean you you can train yourself so now
and then you can do that you know you
can learn to listen to people for
example on the off chance that you might
be wrong but that is by no means a
natural way of thinking and of course
the the the fundamental philosophical
axioms of the scientific method weren't
developed until Descartes and bacon and
who else decart bacon there's one more
anyways the name escapes me at the
moment but you can argue about when
science emerged but you you it certainly
emerged in its articulated form within
the last thousand years I think you
could say even more specifically that it
emerged in the last five hundred years
now you might argue with that and say
well what about the Greeks and other
people who were fairly technologically
sophisticated or who invented geometry
or that kind of thing but yeah yeah
Bayer precursors to the idea of
empirical observation Aristotle for
example when he was writing down his
knowledge of the world it never occurred
to him to actually go out in the world
and look at it to see if what he assumed
about it was true and it certainly never
occurred to Aristotle to get twenty
people to go look at the same thing
independently write down exactly how
they went about doing it compare the
records and then extract out what was
common and that's a that seems
self-evident to us to some degree but
you know it was by no means self evident
to anyone 500 years ago and people still
don't do it so it's not even it's not
plausible if you know anything about the
history of ideas it's not plausible to
posit that stories about the nature of
reality that existed before 500 years
ago were scientific in any but the most
cursory of ways so why we have that are
continually is somewhat beyond me part
of the reason is though that everyone
fundamentalists included really believe
in scientific facts even though they
hate it they'll use computers they'll
fly computers won't work wouldn't work
unless quantum mechanics were correct
like the fact that you use a high-tech
device indicates through your action
that you actually accept the theories
upon which it's predicated right the
same as fly it's the same as anything
you do and into complex technological
society you're stuck with it your
reading by the lights do they work yeah
they work well so it's really hard for
people who are trying to hold on to a
way of looking at the world that appears
to contradict the scientific claims when
everything they do is predicated on
their acceptance of the validity of the
scientific claims it's really Traut
problematic for people and it's
problematic in a real way I think
because one of the problems with the
scientific viewpoint is it doesn't tell
you anything about what you should do
with your life it doesn't does it solve
the problem of value at all in fact it
might make it more difficult because one
of the fundamental scientific claims
roughly speaking is that every fact is
of an equal utility at least from a
scientific perspective right there's no
hierarchy of facts it's not exactly it's
not exactly true because you can think
of one theory is more true than another
but that boils down to saying that it's
more useful than another so I don't
think that that's a really good
exception okay so fine you got the
scientific atheists on one end and you
got the religious fundamentalists on the
other and what they both agree on
whether they like it or not is that
there's so much power in the scientific
method that it's difficult to dispute
the validity of scientific facts and
they seem to exist in contradiction to
the older archaic stories if you also
accept them as fast fact-based accounts
so what do we do about that well if
you're on the scientific atheist end of
things you say well those old stories
are just superstitious science
second-rate barbaric archaic forms of
science you just dispense with them
they're nothing but trouble and if there
are no fundamentalists
you say well we'll try to shoehorn
science into this framework and really
that doesn't work very well it doesn't
work very well with the claims of
evolution for example in fact it works
very badly and that's a problem because
evolutionary theory is like it's a
killer theory and that's really it's
it's it's really really hard and like
it's not a complete theory and there's
lots of things we don't know about
evolution but you know trying to win
hand-wave that way
that's that's not going to work without
dispensing with most of biology so so
that's a big problem so here's another
way of thinking about it you don't just
need one way of looking at the world
maybe you need two ways of looking at
the world and I'm not exactly sure how
they should be related to one another
like which should take precedence under
which circumstance but one problem is
what's the world made of you know what's
the world conceptualized as an objective
place made of another is how should you
conduct yourself while you're alive and
there's no reason to assume that those
questions can be answered using the same
approach
I mean physics has its methods and
chemistry has its methods and biology
has its methods so a method for
obtaining the truth can be bound to a
domain so why would we necessarily
assume that you could use the same set
of tools to represent the world as a
place of objects and to represent it as
a place in which a biological creature
would act
I mean anyways I'm suggesting that we
that we don't view it that way that we
have two different viewpoints maybe they
can be brought together although it's
not obvious how but that it's not a
tenable solution to get rid of one in
favor of the other and I think the
reason for that is that you need to know
how to conduct yourself in the world you
have to have a value system you can't
even look at the damn world without a
value system it's not possible your
emotional health is dependent on a value
system the way you interact with other
people is dependent on a value system
there's no getting away from it and you
say well there's no justification for
any value system from a scientific
perspective you're gonna draw that
conclusion that no value system is valid
where the hell does that leave you
there's no down there's no up there's no
rationale for moving in any direction
there's not even really any rationale
for living and so people fish say things
like that well why why the hell should I
care what happens in a million years
who's gonna know the difference it's
like yeah yeah true stupid but true and
the reason I think it's stupid is
because it's just a game you know I can
take anything of any sort and find a
context in which it's irrelevant it's
just a rational games like who cares if
a hundred children freeze to death in a
blizzard whoo what difference is gonna
make a billion years well what do you
say to someone who says that you say
well seems like the wrong frame of
reference buck oh that's what it looks
like to me you know because at some
point you question the damn frame of
reference not what you derive from it
and it certainly seems to me that
situations like that don't allow you to
use that kind of frame of reference
there's something inhumane about it and
that trumps the logic or at least it
should and if it doesn't then all hell
breaks loose and that doesn't seem to be
a good thing